exclusive this is being let's go ah
there you go next [__] this [__] that's
turbo which I love which are enough
right now
okay I'll come back by every six months
six months now you see me again it's
part one let's go here oh you ready I'm
ready now this vehicle camera ready
let's go y'all ready ready
yeah can we bring out Bill Brasky for a
minute can we do that all right we're
gonna kill the music for Bill Brasky all
right y'all I would like to welcome Bill
Brasky to the show real quick now I've
been around these these tables for while
I've been around these turntables okay
welcoming in myself do upon this fourth
at the bootleg capture these are normal
stipulations that's been done across
from my forefathers it's a 1 William H
Bill Brasky know these terms that have
been probably prevalent and excuse me
for my friend and also relevant upon
thus for justified in the Judah fication
of Love's upon yours your set standards
okay I do declare okay
these stipulations have been male fasted
into a doobie lands and in excellent
upon the self now dealing with a one
William H bill brass
Bill Brasky hey what's the next project
man of course you signed with Diplo
governor yours now we're gonna turn out
I got damn Diplo album we are I got 40
tracks out the way we try and get eight
tracks with then after we get an 80
tracks done we're gonna narrow it down
to 15 we'll come up with the forest the
most bestest we're coming out your roof
with asbestos wait for the crowd to
clear full of AIDS because we can't be
tested hey yo wait a minute wait a
minute son
we're all on the radio right now white
tiger in the studio man we one thing
before before we get you to rap because
of course that's what you do best
why don't you tell us the background
story about James Franco playing it
portraying you in a movie and we talked
about you in in the Spring Break movie
we're never walking away from this the
same Papa getting damn time all right
well right now you can say damn damn is
okay don't spoil it for the crew I
talked about James Franco playing you uh
you know that got you a lot of exposure
all I hear the beat right now
all right the beats off the beat is off
it's better because I can't get too
excited all right all right can we talk
about James Franco and have this whole
movie situation as good old James Franco
so how'd it happen there no good friend
of mine harmony korine you gonna see a
crazy movie coming out okay man let me
tell you he's amazing
whoa whoa Tommy Curran is a [__]
genius okay now when we're dealing with
a James Franco in a whole new firm we're
talking geniuses here folks
when I talk about you everyday
run-of-the-mill just sasquatches running
around with a camera and a fiddle around
the neck making up some imitation movies
and record and I've been putting them
online on YouTube we're talking James
Franco and harmony Krynn what's the name
in the movie spring breakers and James
Franco plays as someone inspired by
yourself exactly hey big Zack have you
seen any like I mean did he do a good
man homemade Corinne Brock about to do I
watched about half of the movie didn't
do good to stop him I had to stop him
halfway through keV what happened I had
to stop ever it was too good it was too
good I wanted to wait till the red
carpet this March when the actual movie
comes out because I want to watch it in
the theaters the same way that everyone
in America and around the world is gonna
watch this movie there it'll be
a platinum coated movie platinum coated
movie platinum coated movie I'm talking
blockbuster hits I'm talking James
Franco River James Franco riffraff hey
oh so can we come with the fact that
James Franco is playing a riff raff do
you know how relevant and how exclusive
that is that's there's only been about
five artists in the history of the world
that's ever been contemplated and
resurrected into a movie true it's a big
deal the fact that I am I'm one of the
ones and aka possibly the only one who
is alive and I haven't even started my
career yet and somebody's already making
a movie about me and I haven't even
dropped a full album yet that's a good
look you're interesting guy riff thanks
again you say the least gotta get you a
reality I know you started off on a
reality show you gotta have a new
reality show let me tell you what for me
to do a reality show I'm charging eight
point five out the gate there it is we
have a sitcom coming out that's ten
points who out the gay alright yo so can
we can we bring the beat back on the
date oh man you wanna freestyle which
one I'm gonna have riffraff man bootleg
cab Ready Set Radio Theo Gio D'Angelo
we're gonna have my man get over this
Tiger Beat okay first of all I'm gonna
show y'all my phone I ain't putting on
there this is freestyle
this isn't that drake blackberry right
yeah buddy
it's that free stop the cranium couldn't
win pratt gnam might go titanium
could a playful little way Neum the way
I come to should've been Orchestra
orchestra could have played for Arkansas
might be saucy the way I come through I
should've play for Boston Boston
flossing now it's gonna cost you ten not
to gate just for feet either
either way ago I gotta blow out your
speakers I should have been a teacher
matter of fact now I'm preaching should
have been in Beacon riffraff up in your
area
now we're getting hysterical I got your
girlfriend parallel parking in my
parking lot parking spot they want to
know if it's dark or not I only wake up
after sundown pull up with my gun down
now she got a draw down now she's laying
facedown if she got a kid and some
stretch marks I don't talk to I don't
even walk to walk to me I come to a
desert he Eagles I come to really
clearly I might get perrolli hairy look
I come through a Pamela Anderson all my
girlfriend's got blonde hair tan skin I
come through in the Phantom
stop all the talking tell your
girlfriend stop talking your boyfriend
get on your cell phone and start texting
he said talk to my girlfriend she's a
transsexual hocus-pocus I come through
why should I did a talk show and I
should've been Oprah I'm gonna come
through my freestyle is still focused
i'ma come through my freestyle is still
Joker clown in the clown name I come
through I'm still the king you see the
master rings I got 10 mil in the bank 50
on the tank hands talking down making
walk the whole plank on my PI rhythm
violin still living silence money on my
candy cause valid riffraff come to I'm
flying autopilot my private plane is
made by Versace I crawl a big body my
shoes and Sorachi stop me somebody stop
me
try to touch my corn believe you were
dead body Sachi on my toe tag you know I
got a damn roaster haters key toasting
now we cheerleading your girl in the
bleachers suckers want to teach us talk
down on me I'm gonna bust you with a
Foley cap yeah real fellow dang we're
fresh canto Jody
talking Joe the high-roller I keep the
peaceful yeah but I told the desert
eagle real fry Oh real quick real quick
you gotta give it up to my building
riffraff man cuz he actually just
freestyle right now there was no phone
no rope nothing a lot of cats can't do
that so sure that's a riffraff man and
we appreciate you coming through there
is been the most interesting
we really do man you got the new Twitter
at Jody high roller our ways everybody
switch over cuz I know a lot of people
might wish you switch it up throws shots
of traps la right now we're gonna do it
we're gonna get a world premiere man
before you get out of here we got this
nine nine nine eleven and panorama droit
you sent me let me turn this up hold on
oh we got what we ain't clean that joint
up no pictures on the beat this is also
a bars Maria riffraff it's an exclusive
for all you guys out here in Phoenix
it's it's a bang there it is man so bang
gonna say the leaf war premier DJ
complexes Ready Set Radio labs ill to
say the least should say the least if
you see riff raff in the streets Bryce
out
Bryce Sun star 98.3 or hip hop Liz